sure i'll start i don't want to stand in
the way of the brilliant observations
i'm sure we'll follow
uh we're in deep doo-doo man
i mean we're we're we're in the grips of
something i think
i'm not sure i can give all the
parameters and i don't want to take too
long
but that i think is a very serious
problem for the country
i think we're out of touch with reality
i think demagoguery is afoot
um i think there's a lot of sophomoric
uh reflections about social
uh problem and organization that has
just consumed
uh uh all the air in the room
and uh we're boxing at shadows and
whatnot
then i'll just give one illustration of
this and i'll stop there's supposed to
be an epidemic of racist
police killings of black people i don't
think that's true i think that's
literally
false uh i don't think these events that
we're observing are even properly
classified as racial
events i think the unreflective
imputation of racial animus to people
who happen to be in one group or another
and who find themselves in conflict
is a deep problem for our society i
think we're losing our way
but like i say i'm just the first of
many people who will make
much more important observations so i'll
desist
thanks glenn john wood
my feeling is that this is
um let me go ahead and say something
optimistic to try and counterbalance
i think some of the justifiable um
pessimism that people may be feeling
this moment
i think that this is a moment of
extraordinary opportunity and
extraordinary danger
and i think that we can focus on the
opportunity in a way that
uh calls forth uh some things that need
to happen right now
i think there is this zealous pursuit
of an ideological victory in favor of a
certain
version of social of social justice
which is
calling for the sort of vast
condemnation of the white
supremacist state it gives the
impression that america is irredeemable
because
its whiteness is something that uh
imbues it with a certain guilt that can
only be
removed through a sort of mass atonement
and capitulation to a series of demands
my feeling is that the is
that america is not a fundamentally
racist nation but that black america
faces problems that are complex
and systemic both of these things can be
true at the same time
and i think that a moment like this is a
moment in which the nation is paying
greater attention
to the plight of black america and if
that happens
in a way to where those energies can be
diverted towards sensitive listening and
an appreciation of the nuances that
govern our reality
then we can make the space for genuine
progress to occur but we have to move
past the demagoguery and the
demonization
that has characterized the conversation
so far that is so heavily invested
in the in this sort of tribal uh
vilified
of certain groups if we get if we can
get past that
then we can use the attention of the
moment to actually break through to
something better
great uh coleman you're up
yes so i think we face
many serious problems as a country
foremost
at this moment is the fact that um
policing is a difficult job
and uh we have
you know the the way the police are
structured
often doesn't provide incentives for
police to be at their best
um we face tricky problems we face
problems that are much harder than
i think would be suggested if you listen
to the dominant rhetoric coming out of
the left-wing activist movement right
now
we we live in a country with more guns
than people
where when police pull someone over they
have
uh to some extent rational fear that the
person might have a pistol hidden in the
glove compartment
and certain police officers deal with
that
as well as it could possibly be dealt
with and other police officers are
are horrible at their jobs but we that
that's a
uniquely american situation because of
how much of a gun country we are
um it's a it's a situation that there is
no
pat or easy solution to
and i think uh i'm more optimistic about
the prospect of never seeing
a george floyd or tony timpa uh like
incident again where somewhere where a
cop is
just has his knee on someone's neck or
upper back and
and essentially kills them in that way
i'm i think it's possible to to
come to a place where we never see an
incident or almost never see an incident
like that
i'm not at all optimistic about getting
to a place where we never see an unarmed
american
of any particular race getting shot by a
cop
um but the problem is i think you know
the media has
prepared black people to think of
this kind of event as something that
only or overwhelmingly happens to black
people and
therefore to react as if our people are
being hunted
by selectively omitting all the cases
where this happens to white people and i
see
lots of what seem like purely
symbolic uh fake solutions to these
problems being offered
reparations how does that help police
brutality
um um you know hiring more
black people at in c-suite positions at
corporations
where's the link between that and fixing
broken public schools so i see lots of
fake solutions being offered to real
problems and
that worries me because they appear in
people's minds to be re
real solutions great
uh thomas hi yeah um
well to pick up on where coleman left
off i actually do think that
um that something some sort of
reparations
uh might go a long way towards uh
or healing some of the divisions in our
society um
i start from the premise that uh race
isn't real
but racism is and that a specific people
that have been in this country
since the collision of europe and africa
400
some odd years ago happened have uh been
failed by their government in this
specific
geography and that a lot of the kind of
inequality could be fixed with some type
of solution that i don't have right now
to go off the top of my head with but
that the idea of reparations might do
something
towards helping racial division i also
think from where i sit
in europe just looking back at um
america it's extraordinary once you
leave to realize how violent a society
it is and how extraordinarily violent
the police are towards all american
citizens
compared to other wealthy societies so
the police kill
upwards of a thousand people a year over
500 of those thousand will be white um
10 out of every million of those of
those thousand will be
um uh native american
it's the the proportion is six out of a
million for
uh for blacks 2.2 out of a million for
whites and
asians are very rarely killed by police
so there is a problem
and whites get the bulk of the numbers
but blacks are disproportionately killed
not in the worst situation compared to
native americans
you can imagine a situation where uh a a
widespread
call for policing reform should be
something that all american citizens are
invested in
and so i think that part of the rhetoric
um as
it's already been said here part of the
rhetoric that this is a uniquely or
specifically black problem
does more to hinder
a lasting and important solution than
trying to find
common ground and common problems to
deal with
excellent john mcwhirter
i think what we're seeing right now at
this moment
is that a certain
radical strain of anti-racism that's
been present for a long time it's been
present
for decades it's
intellectually mediocre
but it's extremely frightening to other
people because one of
its main tenets is that to not agree
with it makes you a racist
so we're in a society where to be called
a racist is essentially equivalent to
being called a pedophile
and you have this minority of people
with this
frankly half cock's notion of
how we should deal with race in the
society that entails
burning everything down and starting
again policing language
in a way that would make it impossible
to say anything the whole philosophy
is based on paradoxes that don't make
any sense it's it's all quite a mess but
there's always been a certain kind of
person
many of them white many of them black
who subscribe to this where
because of what happened to george floyd
and the response to it which i think was
conditioned
actually somewhat fortuitously by how
everybody has been feeling after
quarantine
and it's been a really interesting
series of happenstances
because of that space i think that these
new anti-racist
sense this as a moment when they can
actually take over they sense it as a
useful time when they can make
america believe what they believe
and i don't want to make it sound like
they're evil most people like that are
very nice people who sincerely believe
that what they're thinking is correct
because frankly a lot of them have been
trained not to think very hard about
race it's all very
intellectually mediocre but they're not
going to let go of it
and so the point that we're at right now
is that these people are threatening to
tear down any institution that matters
and
create this kind of orwellian america
they don't know
the evil that they're doing they're not
evil people they don't understand that
their ideas
won't work but it is the time for all
good men
and women and humans to face this mob
down and that hasn't been happening
before generally the ordinary person who
knows that all that stuff is nonsense
goes along with it because they want to
keep their job and they have kids to
raise they have bigger fish to fry it's
completely understandable
but that's not going to work this time
and so i'm wondering
whether the ordinary person who knows
that all of that stuff is a new kind of
stalinism
is going to have it in them to start
saying no
they might not in which case i really do
fear
for what's going to happen on the other
hand i see signs
that they might there might be a way of
keeping this from going any further
than it already has i'd like to see what
happens
this calendar year as we go into the
fall how many people are going to be
capable of standing up
to this sort of thing because after a
few people did after a few organizations
did
then there would be a copycat phenomenon
once once people start to see
the sky won't fall in if somebody says
you're a racist
and you just stand there and say okay
once they realize that the world will
keep spinning
that'll start happening more i hope it
does
all right chloe
so i would say to piggyback on
what has already been said that for me
this looks like a crisis of meaning in
the country
so i think that we are as citizens
increasingly
atomized and isolated both
socially certainly due to covert 19 but
we've been isolated prior to that
and i also think that there's a
spiritual malnourishment in the country
that manifests itself in certain ways
one of which is
racially i think that the way in which
this idea of anti-racism
has been uh proliferating over the past
few months
is a direct product of that spiritual
malnourishment
and so without addressing that
issue we will continue to have these
issues pop
up every so often and
i agree that this will be able to be
sort of kept at bay if the average
person is able to stand up for
themselves and say no
but i'm not sure
if the average person actually has that
fortitude
and that confidence to do so i will say
that i have been approached specifically
because of theory of enchantment
um and the way it actually teaches
uh texts by a lot of the
traditional african-american scholars of
you know the harlem renaissance movement
and such
um i have been i have been approached by
people looking for alternatives
to some of the anti-racist programming
that's been promoted by ibrahim kindy in
the workplace and in corporations and in
schools
i have been approached by people so in
the name of diversity and inclusion
um you know asking me for an alternative
through the theory of enchantment lens
so that is very
i think hopeful just to see that people
are
actually looking for alternatives um
and it's possible that the rise of folks
like ibram cindy and robin d'angelo is
actually very
going to be short-lived um i don't know
we shall see but i also think uh in a
more
hopeful sort of point that
the people writ large the american
people
um in in the same way that we are
susceptible to being sort of whipped
into a frenzy by the media and
and uh susceptible to being polarized
and and sort of turning against each
other again because of that spiritual
malnourishment because we gravitate
toward politics as a form of religion
now
i think we are also encouraged
i've seen encouraging signs that we're
also tired of a lot of this
being whipped into a frenzy and tired of
you know tearing each other apart
at the seams and are really hungry for
something that would actually
be unifying and bring us together so i
think that that is cause for great hope
great camille um
i i do like batting cleanup in a
situation like this because so many
great things have already been said
um and uh while there is some
disagreement
in a couple of specific places i think i
am in broad agreement with the general
theme
uh i will say that i i think it's
important to pay some attention to the
context we find ourselves in i mean this
the country is in
a very vulnerable position we've just
had
uh actually are still in the throes of a
global pandemic
we're at the very beginning i think a
pretty profound economic crisis that
might play
play out over the course of the next
decade and the specific
manifestations of concern like the the
waves of it the paraxis
parrot systems of it um are are
important
but interestingly i i don't know that
that race is so
central to it it's a piece of this
conversation but it isn't all of it just
as policing is a piece of the
conversation but it isn't all of it
um we've seen ourselves sort of kareem
from a place where people are
particularly concerned about an imagined
genocide
against all black people to tearing down
statues and monuments
to reallocation of wealth to
the the inculcation of
these new ideas like the notion that
individuality itself is somehow
a retrograde notion that should be
condemned
and that we should be instituting new
corrective curriculums in our workplaces
and in our schools to try
and introduce new ways of thinking
a lot of a lot of those tendencies
um the the the
interest in sort of re-education and
realignment
it'd be one thing if they were happening
under normal circumstances i think the
fact that they're happening under these
extraordinary circumstances
makes the circumstance all the more
disconcerting
so i do think it's important to have
these conversations about race and
identity
i think it's important to engage on
conversations about structural racism
and yes historic injustices
that have perpetuated certain kinds of
inequality
but i also think it's important not to
lose sight of that broader context
and the degree to which rectifying any
one of those problems
probably doesn't get us out of the bind
that we find ourselves in
[Music]
you